hello and welcome to this video playing
super int mmm super India maybe it's the
Indian flag at least I haven't played
the sky right nope so maybe some kings
in yet I also tried the green felt
recently it's it's very risky against
such a high rated term opponent but yeah
no risk no fun yeah I know that d 5 is
supposed to be dangerous nowadays here
don't do didn't do that I came can be
six or something yeah that'd be six line
is a sideline it's um yeah I don't know
the main lines in any reasonable
detailed so I'm happy to play a sideline
okay let's get rid of this may be Queen
D 70th first yeah can do this first
night might have the root yr c 70 my kid
doesn't do that
hmm yeah okay I cannot go tonight not
develop the night okay maybe I'm taking
a go here for 97 minutes then rook c8
and if I was hanging so I Bishop f4
maybe hmm okay then maybe night a six or
maybe knight c6 actually try to be
active d5 whatever still looks kind of
scary okay I'm putting it here not quite
sure about it
okay let's do this
now it looks it looks scary it really
looks scary I just wonder I mean okay
this is the group hug yeah it's all
about tactical awareness what about if I
take you for am I getting killed down I
know I don't see it at the moon Queen
takes form hmm I don't see it why why
isn't that working I can take all kinds
of stuff that the end is gotta check
check check check and I'm throating made
maybe I'm still some trouble there but I
don't see it come on I'm taking this if
you okay I don't know why this not
working local same Jack I thought I
would be good here the rook is hanging
you can check check check quincy aid
bishop evade and I'm threatening 9726
Shack should work
check I actually thought I haven't made
but okay I don't have homemade green on
CA discovering means that now only have
this one
now it should be okay at least not sure
if I'm better but I should be okay Queen
and night are notoriously tricky but I'd
have six King h8 don't see anything
right there for him check ok ok I cannot
go to g7 chord quite clearly yeah go
into e72 a Tekkit it's not attacking
this actually
you see threatening something let's try
to figure that one out don't see it at
the moment maybe I just move this stuff
move the pieces and move the pawns I'm
sorry
near queen is seven intending King g7
was an alternative but not sure how
great this is it's nice to have this
pawn but he's also very much dominating
my pieces him yeah so they have to go go
to g7 here right
hmm it's actually surprising okay he
wants to do what exactly 95 I guess 95
okay I cannot go Bishop e7 here Queenie
seven is probably drawing let's do this
first and see if he has something great
here probably not on time or needs to
this try a little bit here at least
that's the self Penrod no 25 I'm sorry
25 I've got f6 check
check okay
yeah that's right offer I tried to offer
draw a mite try to play on my bedtime
social position is nothing I could have
played 25 check check check no blunder
Josh five now so we can actually claim
to have wind wonders on position check
yeah it was a bit bad i mean okay I
shouldn't should lose of course I should
rather win the position but ok black
resigns yeah I couldn't couldn't make
this work here I mean black black is
clearly better of course but I couldn't
quite make it work a three is better now
yeah okay here you can jack and draw
with this and yeah here just like I mean
Black is just yeah I mean I'm a little
bit better because of this porn that I
can never win so it's it's a total draw
but okay I lost a bit more time here
trying to figure out how to win I mean
I've could have drawn a couple of times
very easily even check of course you
want to win if the other guy had
blundered upon check yeah ok so it's
a quick look at this yeah so around here
it looks fairly normal probably bit
better for white like this this and yeah
some somewhere around TMP but I can just
take it yeah blundered that porn but
he's got selectivity so probably check
it is enough to draw him he has enough
activity here so queen to d6 I had to
play exactly oops check of course yeah I
can never go here habits and he
definitely has enough activity to draw
but I think he um probably tried a
little bit too hard I don't know trying
to play for win yes um probably not i'm
not justified objectively yeah well the
engine wants to go a three and says that
i'm katie better I mean and this is so
difficult for a human player so I don't
have the time time and time here yeah
this allowed him to escape to that draw
an ending yeah and okay with no time on
the clock well he just wins on time here
ok guys thanks for watching